you know I always wonder like if you
were to go to your house in my head
like do you have like a museum and and
let's say the museum door opens up and
in the museum is like the first rubber
band necklace displayed the Gucci
headbands on display I got the Gucci
headband the sunglasses you know it's
crazy they just came
I don't want to say like I don't know
what channel I don't know what TV show
it probably has an area I'm probably
supposed to say but they're gonna put it
like in the one of them you know I'm
saying Hall of Fame joints I gave them
the glasses you gave him the glass I
gave him the glasses so they putting
them in there but did I keep the Gucci
head back there I kept the Gucci head
man that [__] so dirty it looks
God by the end of the last interview you
did in it it Deb is dirty as [__] yeah I
got it though isn't I got you can see it
in there I'm like nah let's just put
that God damn that was an error yeah it
was I'm a save I gotta say that that was
a [__] error that got to see headband
you can never get rid of that you can't
yeah no that should go into like a
Smithsonian
some of the most memeable moments of all
time were with that headband on Drake
it's not for real hey uh so I obviously
we all ended up here in uh you on what
you are were you on donda too yeah you
were on down to two which uh by the way
I had to buy this [__] thing to
listen to that was hard I bought this
[__]
this stem player damn player
I haven't used it since right two
hundred dollars
got me for sure
um and you were supposed to be on the
first donda you got to take it off right
yeah yep yep was that something you sent
into Kanye or and what was it what was
because you had like been kind of you
were kind of [__] on you a little
bit when you didn't make the album but
then you ended up making Donna too so
what was the makeup like because he hit
you up like hey man my bad bro this is
wild enough and you know how I get I
just like to speak my mind keep it real
man like you know what I'm saying you
were wilding out on Instagram today all
the time yeah I'm saying every day but
you know it's just that's just me you
know what I'm saying you know but you
know I just I just speak my mind and I
feel like he could have just you know
left kept my verse on the album you know
man you had to do all that and then the
verse he actually included doesn't even
come out on dsps it's on this [__]
stem player that nobody [__] uses you
know what I'm saying but it was cool to
go in redo the verse get it done you
know what I'm saying and everybody was
happy everybody was happy so have you
talked to yay recently is he good I
don't know if you guys chat ever well
next time I saw yeah yeah but you know
he got he got a lot going on you know
what I'm saying so it's kind of like I'm
assuming he's not doing many bar
mitzvahs anymore I don't know what he
got going on you know what I'm saying
but like you know I just try to like
when you see stuff like that just
support you know that's right because
like when everything cool and everything
all good it's cool you know we could
play around with control but we see
somebody going through serious stuff for
sure just pause everything like you just
send them love and support you know what
I'm saying I do feel like you've done a
really good job of mastering the
internet how much of the [__] you say
online are you like very self-aware on
it's gonna go viral
this is going to be a thing I mean I
don't know I just talk some stuff I say
people don't even post it you know what
I'm saying but most of the stuff I say
they post it you feel me so I just try
to be like just be my be yourself you
know sound like man I mean be myself
keep it real and that's what's going on
what's the last thing that you were the
first rapper to do I just did some first
rapper [__] the other day
what was that first rapper [__] I did we
were somewhere I was the first rapper to
do uh damn I just did some first rapper
[__] the other day I ain't gonna come I
forgot you should do a first rapper book
like each page is like Soulja Boy was
the first rapper too yeah do this what I
just did I was someone they said you the
first rapper dude it was real too I
forgot I'm gonna remember I forgot you
say yeah yeah it was like last week it
was last week yeah like you gotta stop
smoking so much weed if you can't
remember you feel me it's like it was
something it was yesterday I don't know
what happened [__] I prefer rapper to do
something
yeah I forgot uh so when's the tour
start August August man you know I'm
saying yeah come on check out this we're
gonna be L.A Cali we're gonna be all
over this line are you going over
Seasons overseas later you know what I'm
saying overseas uh this whole run is U.S
Run August September what uh is your
favorite City to perform in that isn't
in the U.S so far because you've ever
seen you've done some wild like random
places I gotta pick one I can say
something yeah do a couple sure Dubai
for show like Dubai would be lit can't
take the weed there though but you don't
need it like Dubai so lit you're not
even thinking about the weed like okay
they having Lamborghini you've been in
Dubai of course not they go what no I've
not been to Dubai I'd like to go you
gotta go bro you got the passport don't
it yeah of course like the next time I
do a show and see hey for a rapper to
take before I rap [__] again for a
rapper to take care of the [__]
Dubai y'all [__] ain't took care of
the Dubai yet what the [__] y'all [__]
tripping okay how long you been doing
this [__] like 20 years damn yeah almost
15 15 16. that's slow enough they got me
[__] up they got us [__] up they got
you [__] up what you mean Cam ain't
been to buy it and you got the password
I ain't got my passport no I got my
passport I'm a girl got your past what's
that we going to Dubai y'all [__]
tripping so you love Dubai where else
okay boom Paris Paris is great I've been
there Eiffel Tower
[__] Brazil I'm saying Germany have
you been to Amsterdam Amsterdam see
before we was legal in America we was at
the coffee shops no you know about the
coffee shop yeah and the coffee shop is
getting hot they having so much weed you
go in the coffee shop these people put
weed in your coffee right you can drink
the weed with coffee they having all
type of Trades you pulling them out they
having all flavors in Amsterdam in
Amsterdam like it's the trap house but
it's so cold it's cold but I love it
though did you uh partake in the red
light area of districts I'm I may have I
may have not of sorts
we may have may have uh experienced
something of the sort I heard like if
you walk through there's like walk
through that's all you got is that's
what we call it there's like a section
the walk through if you need a Latin
girl this is where they are there's the
and then there's the the walkthrough
yeah if I'm not mistaken
they be in the windows
they in the Windows like a [__]
mannequin on this plate